[Applauso]
oggi finalmente uscito il nuovo schema
gelataio cattiva è uscito ice scream 4
non vediamo l'ora di vedere che cosa
succederà cosa scopriremo ancora sulla
vita di rod se volete vedere un secondo
game play di ice cream 4 la famiglia c'è
qualcosa e se questo video raggiunge i
10 mila mi piace si sarà un altro
gameplay così potrebbe anche esserci un
ice scream 4 nella vita reale tantissimo
ma ora non perdiamo altro tempo se siete
già modi
mettetevi al buio se volete avere ancora
più paura re del pop corn e iniziati
eccoci qua sono super emozionata
ovviamente alla fine del video scrive
tesi che voto di date da 1 a 10 non
riusciremo ovviamente a finirlo tutto
tra l'altro hanno messo l'italian ora
abbiamo tutto in italiano siamo facile
parola perché ho paura che sarà un po
difficile
iphone 4 ecco eccolo questa è la
fabbrica di gelati la fabbrica di ice
cream sta entrando guardate in road dica
ma un gigante da gigante adoro anche le
musiche sono bellissimi avrà portato
qualche bambino e credo proprio di sì
ama tra l'altro lui dentro entra dalla
pasta liscia
eccolo ove ne minò una nuova vittima di
rod lo trasformerà in serata sarà un
nostro amico sicuramente ho preso tutti
i bambini di sotto choc ingresso i
bambini guardali nelle loro gabbie ho
preso tutti i bambini i bambini ci si
farà un gran bel gelato che cattivo qua
davanti a qui ci siamo noi siamo stati
freddi si sta già stati presi bene bene
bene bimbi
eccovi di nuovo riuniti vi lascia soli
un istante così che possiate raccontarvi
le vostre avventure
non mettetevi troppo comodi meno ma è
che stanza è questa
resto in tre reti nella mia stanza fuori
ciale di strizzano fino all'ultima
goccia
quindi dobbiamo scappare da rod è così
vicino da questa gabbia e salvare i tuoi
amici
wow c'è già adoro dobbiamo scappare
dalla fabbrica di gelate salvare tutti
che ci possa interagire con questa banca
è accaduto qualcosa che combini road è
un road piccolino il figlio di rod forse
perché il road piccolino sarà il figlio
che carino però un piccolino
dobbiamo e attenti a non farsi vedere un
artiglio di roth
ok sono riuscito ad aprire il lucchetto
di riuscire a salvare i tuoi amici di
secondare attento che anche debora
niente che non possa che raggiungeranno
a mano in questa mano probabilmente
entro solo dentro la gabbia vedi dovrà
mettere dentro alla coppia raddoppiano
piano intorno non mi sa che il
visitatore allarme arm e messi
quindi ora arriva roth ricorda quanto
non sai come procederà poi lasciata
dalla finestra dell'indizio è già super
avvincente questo gioco può venire anche
un po di ansia a siamo in bagno ok che
succede
sala di controllo questo però ecco
dovrai sbarazzarti di questo robot per
accedere alla sala di controllo a
liberare i tuoi amici
mi sa che da qui però non possiamo
passare al programmatore di qua quello
mi fa ancora più paura di rose e gigante
cioè si distrugge ma cosa c'è qui non
core da roba ma non c'è niente
a cosa ti aspettavi dal nuovo gelato
sono queste cose qualche indizio ho
fatto tenere il quadro ora rotte gigante
porto lo schermo che successo si scrive
ha già preso mi restano due tentativi
per torvare non si prima che la fabbrica
chiuda siamo tornati in gabbia
il figlio di rod e uno spione chiuso a
chiave che occhi strani me stesso come
facciamo ad uscire da qui agli occhi spr
inquietanti ok proviamo a vedere un
indizio perché non riusciamo a uscire da
questa gabbia per scappare dalla gabbia
di ritrovare un oggetto che apra la
serratura ma questo già ieri continua
viene troppo alte ok siamo aperto la
gabbia
non se n'è accorto non si era accorto o
no speriamo successione chiuso
dobbiamo ritornare negli uffici immagino
più piano sto porto e bloccato non si
può aprire bloccata da degli assi
vediamo qualcosa c'è ma quindi quindi
siamo molto vicini che controllano
qualità magistrale ok ok
pensavo fossimo già nella camera di
controllo vediamo come sempre guardare
tre mesi sono geloso open sea ray gelato
non ci credo ho trovato giocato rosa
vitale viene distratto da frate cosa
servirà la cosa era quello quello è il
road gigante che cos'è cortivo nel cara
laboratorio questo è il garage
la rodriguez si tramanda costa niente
vabbè io vado via da qui dobbiamo
riuscire a liberare gli altri beh io
vado nella stanza segreta
no infatti non si può entrare mannaggia
ma che cos'è questo coperto attento ha
chiamato l'allarme questa fase per
controllarci
io devo dire grazie
sempre sulla seconda volta è già un
ultimo tentativo
eccoci qua stiamo nuovamente nella
coppia
dobbiamo trovare un altro iniziativa per
uscire quel che musica netto su questo
la serratura più tour quindi forse
possiamo rom per la quarta prendiamo la
cosa inesatta presa per no perché lì per
lì mi sta ora possiamo rompere il
lucchetto forse troviamo abbiamo perso
già la terra non puoi sfondare palmento
da qui ore si potrebbe scoprirsi ma se
ti muovi miss andare al piano di sotto e
aprire il pavimento brava ottima idea è
piaciuta per 80 forse bisogna andare da
qui dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per aprire
questa porta acqua siamo tornati
mettiamo forse road non è più quale
possiamo esplorare meno nella sotto
guardando vederci già ma si può scendere
[Musica]
devi prendere il piede di porco che c'è
sul tavolo per poi aprire quella porta
sicuramente ero brava a recco lo prendi
lo prendo dissi a scappare da rho dove
facciamo da qui pensavo si potesse
salire e invece no si poteva prendere la
scarpa
[Musica]
sia trasformato in gelati aiuto a me lo
sta portando questa la forma con totti
che gelato diventeremo corretto
io sono il solo rod l'ha fatta franca t
e trascinato nella camera di estrazione
tv si rimane rete rinchiusi allungano la
sua fabbrica chi di voi avrà il coraggio
di affrontarlo di ok abbiamo
ricominciato perché vogliamo scoprire
cosa c'è oltre a questa porta e
purtroppo sia il figlio di road che sta
girando qua intorno quindi non riusciamo
subito ad andare a prendere
quell'attrezzo maioglio saper cosa fare
in modo da qui che stiamo tornando al
laboratorio che cos'era il garage e
purtroppo c'è sempre road dobbiamo stare
supera attenti a prendere l'attrezzo lo
vedi è la sotto forse non ci credo
new york ce l'ha più fatta verso lo
chiamò subito a vedere cosa c'è oltre
quella bordi e io ne so dovrei uscire da
qui la peta che così apriamo questa
porta speriamo che non sia vero
ok noi e devi fare ad uno ad uno
superpomodoro tempo c'è il video di rod
che gira e controlla non ho visto lì via
via qualche c'era adesso veloce solo
questa keep on o adesso no l'italia
perda anche fatti
non lo so però se ci nascondiamo qua
sotto forse non ci provano adotterà voci
fonte qualcosa di più interessa posso
capire se la scala io non ci credo il
figlio di ronda chiamato road perché
avevamo solo chi c'è l'altro do magg
tanta roba da spiegato che proviamo
scendere sosta magari c'è qualcos'altro
che non abbiamo visto però non si fosse
grande lì non è qui quindi possiamo
esplorare un po prima che arrivi
possiamo prendere il campione andare da
un'altra parte forlì buona idea vede
meno forse non perché lo sta sistemando
la forza è rotto non si può aprire il
camion questa porta non si può aprire al
piano a prendere questa scala a quarta
forse si può salire su cui è bravo ad
esso doveva avere in questa vita ecco
qua copertuta critico volte potere è
fissato alla parete
dobbiamo usare quell'attrezzo che
abbiamo usato prima o cesserà qualche
altro aspetto vite apple nuovo paura che
sia arrivato rob cassetto non si può
aprire dove darà il calcio mi cacciavite
cacciavite dove come ho fatto ad
arrivare alla più puri anche sentito qui
abbiamo ancora questa scala in mano
bisogna fare allarme
è la notte circa ci avete qua prima mi
sta arrivando il respiro no cerchiate di
porco però ma non so se mi può servire
diamo un solvente altro qua dentro il
gol
il coroner è stato di diritto borseggio
nel camioncino casta
no non c'è perché l'ha chiamato su forza
adesso proviamo riconosciuta tecnica per
farmi allontanare da fare e farsi vedere
dai figli di road perché mi sembra che
sono due abbastanza abbiamo scoperto una
nuova stanza wow che sono tutte queste
cose vediamo controlliamo se troviamo
qualcosa quel trofeo cosa abbiamo fatto
veramente può trovare un sacco di cose
atella soto riproviamo ad aprire quella
parte lì anche se ci vorrebbe una mucca
tramite il condotto porta una nuova area
per aprire la griglia deve rimuovere le
viti con cui è fissato ma che ho visto k
forse questo brano riesci a salire se si
guarda aiuto io ti aspetto ha
prospettato il mood male o non ci sta
inseguendo
ecco a te il casco nascondo qui ok forse
qua non si trova dentro il quale allora
porta chiedo perché
ha preso bene questo era il nostro primo
black ice cream 4 ma se volete che lo
continuiamo lasciato un bel mi piace
questo 13 milioni di vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quello che
preferite
buona visione